you mentioned that interview with with
uh Gavin Nome um I think it's worth just
playing a bit from that that interview
uh because I would like to get your
thoughts on yeah the content uh of what
he was saying there let's roll
that during
Co um you you were pretty strict with
the lockdowns here and uh there was an
interesting piece in Harpers that sort
of was critic critical of your decisions
from this perspective
you found a way to allow the motion
picture industry and sou and the and the
sort of the movie industry to get back
to work but you didn't allow people to
grieve together at funerals or at
churches and that it sort of and that
this may be why there's such a polarized
disconnect what what you prioritize
right this is this anger between the
populace and the elite supposedly here
you prioritize this
industry but you you know you were
tougher on those that just want wanted
to go worship what do you say to that
Chris I think there's a lot of humility
and we didn't know we didn't know and it
was hardly I it was we collectively I
think all of us in in terms of our
Collective wisdom we've evolved we
didn't know we didn't know we're experts
in hindsight we're all Geniuses but
think about what we what you PR what you
ended up collectively prioritizing
you're prioritizing industry you know
one one specific one but then didn't
prioritize maybe on that whose maybe
values you didn't connect with I don't
think it's a binary there was iterations
within that theme there was there was
fits and starts there were Regional
Frameworks uh that had impacts more
broadly defined there were more industry
specific uh uh Frameworks all of us went
through a process I mean there was few
states that didn't go on aggressive
lockdowns including uh Florida's Rond I
understand that but it was more with but
within the framework of who opened the
door it's what industry got yeah
leniency in which which all of it is all
of it is legitimate in terms of of
reflection all something you do
differently I think a whole we would
have done everything differently because
we understood we would understand
Outdoors as an example nature you would
to shut schools down you to try to
figure out how to maybe have outdoor
classrooms no that's not well now you're
getting I'm being but I think the nature
of the spread early on in understanding
the epidemiology of that spread
understanding the spread in the context
of how it spread very differently
indoors than Outdoors is one perfect
example what a lot of us would have done
differently including again in states
red states that shut down their beaches
in the early part of the
pandemic so his defense is kind of you
know we didn't know what we didn't know
and we all kind of you know would have
done things differently what do you
think of that aarin I I think we did
know and there were people like me in
the state there were people like J
bachara at Stanford in the state there
were many of us who were speaking out
who were criticizing these polic icies
from the very beginning starting in 2020
continuing through
2021 we had the epidemiological evidence
to understand that lockdowns which had
never previously been tested and were
never part of pandemic planning uh prior
to 2020 and had been rejected by the
public health establishment uh when did
you all ever try to get like an audience
with Nome or any local officials if so
absolutely all of us were trying to get
a hearing and in fact we were silence we
were suppressed in some cases we were
fired but even when we weren't fire
fired our universities vilified us um
people accused us of wanting to kill
grandma and so this whole it wasn't I it
was we no go back and look at the
stay-at-home order it was signed by
Gavin Nome go back and look at his press
conference when he announced the first
lockdown in California it was very much
I am ordering us to do this and I am
taking responsibility for this so we
didn't know any better as nonsense many
of us did and we were silenced vilified
and in some cases lost our
jobs and I'm not responsible because all
of us and our thinking has evolved it's
a big we is just a Dodge of
responsibility you're the executive
you're the one who declared a state of
emergency within California gained
additional extra Constitutional Powers
and utilize those powers in ways that
were nously damaging the effects of
which will be felt for decades the
effects of school closures the effects
of lockdowns will be felt for
decades so I have no patience for this I
have no patience for this dodging of
responsibility I'm glad he admitted yeah
we would do everything differently now
um you know so you feel sort of
Vindicated as a Critic of lockdown
school closures and mask and vaccine
mandates but um but it's he's hardly
admitting responsibility he's hardly
admitting uh that he was wrong you know
he's he's I don't know he's trying to
deflect responsibility onto some sort of
anonymous Collective blob and that
that's not how that's not how a leader
behaves a leader takes responsibility
for his or her own decisions thanks for
watching that clip from our conversation
with Aaron karotti about the return of
coid man dates and his book the new
abnormal you can watch another clip from
that conversation right here or the full
conversation over here